Come back to me our greatest weapon
against darkness isn't our superpowers
it's our humanity and our love for each
other i know this is right i have faith son
we will get iris back oh god i'm still
here this enemy is all-powerful it's
not just mirrors she's manipulating it's
any reflective surface requesting backup
i called in a little bit of extra muscle
anyone can save the world with their might
it takes a real hero to do it with his heart i
know how to open a portal to the mirror verse
i'll never stop fighting to reach you
what are you a product of your broken mind
give me back my wife then you have one
percent of your speed left. Let's make it count.
Run Barry, run.
When we were dreaming about having a
family didn't look like this did it
lost jobs teens with severe
anxiety parents gone too soon.
why'd you move the family here
still looking for the simple life
Cause those days are gone clark long gone
you got the weight of the world on your
shoulders really wish i could get drunk sometimes
you're saying you're superman no we've seen
superman before we've seen him am i a bad father
we're going to be all right no one ever dreams
about the problems but every life has them
even the extraordinary ones superman and lois
two-hour premiere event tuesday february 23rd
stream free next day only on the cw app
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my flash season 7 trailer also
talk about the very man of steel looking superman
trailer because that show's going to be starting
really soon too if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
since there's so much stuff that's coming back in
2021 things are looking so much better than last
year because of all the virus stuff i'll explain
what my episode plan is during the video too
but i'll talk about the flash footage first then
i'll talk about the man of steel superman trailer
the whole thing with the first few episodes of
the flash season seven is that they're essentially
doing the cancelled episodes that were supposed to
come at the end of season six last year they had
to cancel production on all the shows last year in
2020 because of the virus so the final few mirror
master episodes or mirror mistress whatever you
want to call her were originally supposed to wrap
up they take her down and there was supposed to be
a big reverse flash twist with them creating the
new artificial speed force that would have pushed
them into season seven and tease another big twist
in the real version of godspeed that's supposed
to be one of the main villains of season seven the
flash footage pretty much just starts with someone
zapping another person with speed force energy i
think it's just a reference to barry losing the
last embers of his regular speed force powers
if you're a big my hero academia fan if you watch
anime it's like all might losing the dying embers
of one for all as he's passed it on there's a
tiny little bit that's left before he uses it up
united states of smash for the win that's the
whole reason for them creating this artificial
speed force clearly chester p runk is the key to
completing that project they tried during season
six and failed but it sounds like they'll
be successful when the season starts again
you get a classic joe west pep talk during the
trailer trying to stop barry from crying again
unsuccessfully one of the flash's other super
powers is crying a lot frequently when he comes
out of this storage chamber this probably looks
familiar this is where they used to keep the
old flash costume on the dummy but it seems like
they've turned it into some sort of speed force
regeneration chamber to try and temporarily boost
his abilities they hype up opening a portal to the
mirror verse that gets into more multiverse travel
obviously that also connects back to what they did
during crisis on infinite earths with the whole
ezra miller justice league flash cameo scene going
full multiverse they're actually filming the flash
movie in april while they'll still be filming
flash episodes so i'm sure we'll start hearing
more about whether or not grant gustin is actually
going to get a cameo in the flash movie hopefully
john wesley's shipped too i'll do more videos when
we get more news about that the justice league
snyder cut is coming out in march so expect more
talk about what's going on with the flash movie
around then too there will be a new justice league
snyder cut trailer sometime pretty soon too it's
just a coincidence that the flash season seven
also starts in march they delayed it by one week
because the superman episode one is going to be
extra long with a special documentary about the
superman character they're turning that premiere
into a much bigger thing so i'll talk about that
in a second when i talk about the superman footage
so dearborn is back she's going to be
a serious regular during season seven
the way they cut the footage they want you to
think the extra muscle that he calls in is killer
frost but it could always be somebody else too
it's just that danielle panabaker had her baby in
real life a while ago so she's been back filming
episodes regularly like the rest of the cast
but then after they start hyping up traveling
to the mirror verse and you see them intercut
between the scenes of barry trying to open
the speed force wormhole to the mirror verse
with the footage of him next to the machine that
they're using to create the artificial speed force
this seems like reverse flash who's saying run
bury run so this could be reverse flash actually
coming back or it could just be very hallucinating
reverse flash saying it because the last we saw of
him he had lost his body and he was just formless
negative speed force energy looking for another
body to possess and i think we all assumed that
that was a setup for the red death speedster twist
from the comics he become an evil fusion speedster
gogeta dragon ball style it also kind of looks
like barry's about ready to crap his pants when
he's listening to him say that too but then moving
to the superman footage the big thing here is that
one the trailer is in movie aspect ratio not the
regular 16x9 aspect ratio of all the dc tv shows
because they want it to feel more cinematic more
special than the normal cw shows so the entire
pilot episode that we watched like episode 1
might be completely in movie aspect ratio but i
don't know if the entire show is gonna be movie
aspect ratio the look of the episode and the whole
tone of the trailer itself feels very inspired by
henry cavill's man of steel movie as if they've
completely rebooted this character from the
original supergirl tv show version which i think
a lot of people were excited by because i think a
lot of big superman fans were disappointed with
what they did with that character on that show
so this is them sort of doing their own thing like
okay crisis on infinite earths happen we're going
to re-tune and reboot some of the things about
this character so he'll feel more like you would
expect superman to feel during his tv show when
that starts they also use that excuse to give him
a huge superman costume upgrade it's way better
than the old one they also said that practically
the reason for the upgrade is because the old
suit on the supergirl tv show wasn't designed to
be worn for long periods of time so i am way more
excited to see what the actual episodes feel like
like a more grown-up version of smallville
mixed with man of steel and a little bit of
the lois and clark energy because the title
of the show is actually superman and lois
like you'll notice in the past when we had
superman scenes they've used the smallville
version of the kent farm but on this show the
kent farm looks exactly like the kent farm from
the man of steel movie so it's just more of that
henry cavill superman energy baked into the show
the whole thing with the crisis on infinite earth
reboot too obviously is that they went from having
the one baby john kent from the comics to having
two sons and they're both teenagers now the scene
of them at the daily planet is referencing clark
kent being downsized from the show because when
episode one picks up the economy's kind of gone
to [ __ ] the paper's losing money because most
newspapers in real life aren't very profitable
nowadays it's also how they explain the twist
of him coming back to smallville to raise their
sons in smallville on the farm wall is also busy
being superman 24 7 saving everyone all over the
world then you get the dylan walsh voice over as
general sam lane lois father they've recast this
character like there was a version of general lane
on the super girl tv show but they also
gave him a big upgrade with this actor
you probably recognize him from somewhere he's
been on a billion different tv shows and movies
i believe he's supposed to be one of the main
antagonists of season one like they have the
big boss fight during the trailer that'll probably
be the villain of episode one that he takes down
but there'll be a couple other big bads during the
season and some mystery characters they haven't
fully revealed yet this is the older son he's john
kent from the comics the younger son here is named
jordan kent which is a reference to jordan elliott
the alias that superman used during the man
of tomorrow story which itself is meant to be a
reference to jorel jordan elliott jor-el so their
two sons are named for superman's two fathers but
then this is their new version of lana lange she's
also going to be a main character on the show also
living in smallville and they're doing you know
big deep cut here kind of a man of steel version
of the superman 3 movie twist where she's with a
version of the brad character and it's kind of a
bad marriage you remember that that was annette
o'toole during superman 3 playing the lona lane
character then she became martha kent during the
smallville tv show so it's this big never-ending
continuum of easter eggs and callbacks to the
movies and the tv shows the bigger twist obviously
that everyone's talking about to the trailer
is that they're really saying that the boys
have had no idea that their dad is superman
this whole time somehow he's managed to hide that
from them their whole lives which kind of seems
weird but that's also probably just part of their
story arcs discovering that they also have powers
and start to manifest during the show and i know
a lot of you are asking will the smallville actors
from that show cameo on the new superman tv show
i feel like that's a pretty easy slam dunk so
anyone that wants to probably will eventually show
up on the series tom welling could come back any
time he wants of course they want him to come back
but that's just dependent upon him wanting to come
back personally i'd rather see michael rosenbaum
come back as a version of wally west because he's
never played live action wally west even though
he did the voice of animated wally west during
the justice league tv series he be like the jake
johnson spider-man into the spider-verse version
of wally west then separately even though he
doesn't show up in the trailer david ramsey
also signed a crossover deal to show up on
a couple of the cw shows this year he'll be
coming to superman for a couple episodes and
directing a superman episode so it sounds like
they'll also do some diggle green lantern stuff
on the superman tv show i think we kind of assumed
that after the aero finale too because he said
that he was moving to metropolis so it's like oh
they'll pay off all this green lantern stuff on
the superman tv show i'm not exactly sure how i'm
gonna schedule my videos for the episodes when
those shows start because they're gonna overlap
with the Wandavision falcon and winter soldier
the loki episodes on disney plus so i'll have
to adjust how i do videos for the cw stuff as we
go along we won't start getting the hbo max the
suicide squad tv show the hbo batman tv show till
much much later though of course i'll be doing
videos for those too when they eventually premiere
an obviously reminder that all of warner brothers
movies not just the dc movies this year will
be coming to hbo max but if you spotted any big
easter eggs that i didn't mention in the video or
you have big questions about what's happening with
the shows just write them below in the comments my
Wandavision episode 5 video will post this friday
you can click here for that Wandavision episode
5 trailer video with all those wtf scenes and
click here for that brand new thor 4 love and
thunder first look with the guardians of the
galaxy thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!